Speaker 1: One of the most popular sort of
punching bags for conservatives right now
is the state of California.
They love to say California is a liberal hellhole.
California is what happens when the left wing
policies of Democrats run rampant.
But the truth is that that's bogus.
And a few weeks ago, I did a story called
so-called failed state of California sets
economic growth record.
And in that story, I went through the economic
data and it turns out California is actually
doing really well.
Economic growth is some of the highest in
the US and California.
The economic surplus in California, the budget
surplus is at a record level.
So those claims about California throughout
the pandemic have been false.
Another talking point is people are fleeing
California.
Everybody's leaving California.
It's going to be left empty.
The cupboards will be bare of people, as Trump
likes to say.
We now have a new study about that.
And it is also just a lie.
Republicans want to paint California as a
place that people are just desperate to get
out of, they'll go anywhere.
They'll just get me out of California.
And it never passed the sniff test because
if people really were getting out there, magical,
perfect, rational market would lead to a significant
drop in the cost of living in California.
Basic supply and demand rents would go down,
property values would go down.
That's not happening.
But putting the sniff test aside, there's
a new study from the University of California
system which found that the number of people
moving out of California into other states
is up slightly compared to 2012.
But it's at very similar numbers to what we
saw throughout the mid and late 2000s.
There are some people moving out as people
move that move out of any state, but at historically
sort of normal levels.
Meanwhile, there are still young people moving
into California at relatively high rates.
They're also going other places.
Some of them are going to Texas, some of them
are going to Colorado.
You do see some older folks moving out of
California, but it's really no big deal.
The percentage of Californians who plan to
leave the state when you ask them has remained
basically the same over the last two years.
Twenty three percent of California California
voters say I am seriously considering leaving
the state.
That was twenty four percent two years ago.
Basically the same.
That sounds huge.
And obviously, if a quarter of California
left California, it would be a cataclysm economically.
But remember that most people who say they're
considering leaving don't.
I mean, I've been considering moving to Miami
for five years and then I realize I don't
really know anybody there.
I'd be far from my family.
I'm going to stay put, at least for now.
But like if you ask me at many points, I would
consider leaving and going to Florida.
Sure.
Yeah, that's something I've considered.
I'm not really going to do it.
And that's for most people.
One interesting thing is that there's a big
partizan gap, though, on that question.
If you ask Democrats.
Twenty one percent say I'm considering leaving
California asked Republicans, 30 percent say
I'm considering leaving California.
No surprise politically, it's very in vogue
right now to say you're thinking of leaving
California.
And guys, I'll do it.
Don't make me because I'm just one day from
renting a U-Haul and getting out of here.
Most people don't do it.
And it's important to remember that if people
did leave California in large numbers, the
heroic, perfect market that the Republicans
love to harp on would lead to lower prices.
That's what Republicans claim is the problem
in California.
They say prices are too high, a real estate
cost too much rent is too damn high.
That's caused by demand.
There's a reason it's more expensive to live
in San Francisco than it is to live in, you
know, Tulsa, Oklahoma, no offense to Oklahoma,
to education is better in California.
There are higher salaries in California than
in Oklahoma.
There's more access to culture.
There's more access to airports with direct
flights to the rest of the world.
There's a higher standard of health care.
There's better infrastructure.
Demand drives prices up.
Doesn't mean people in Oklahoma are bad people.
It's just the market that these right wingers
point to.
That's why it's expensive to be in California.
But right wingers just feel like everybody's
leaving California.
So do we pay attention to facts or do we pay
attention to feelings?
I forget how that statement goes.
Over time, people may leave California, who
knows?
But it's just not happening right now to any
significant degree.
California's not failing economically and
people are not fleeing California.
That's the truth.
It may change in the future, but it's not
happening right now